SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Welcome
everyone.
My name is Scott.
I'm a software engineer on the
map rendering team in Seattle.
JONAH JONES: And I'm Jonah, I'm
the design lead for Maps.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Today
we're going to cover
four different things.
First, we're going to try to get
you inspired to create a
map of all your own.
Second, we're going to cover
three design principles that
lead you through the process of
creating the perfect map.
And then we're going to cover
some building blocks that are
all the different ways that
you can change the
map to what you want.
And lastly, we're going to
combine the design principles
with the building blocks and
put it into practice.
JONAH JONES: All right.
So what is the perfect
map for your site?
Is it the standard Google map?
Is it a colorful map?
Is it a monotone map?
Is it a subtle map?
Or is it something else?
Old Maps Online let you find
historical maps and libraries
around the world.
And they've got a map
that really feels
historical and old.
They've got a faded color
palette, they've got this cool
kind of grain effect that
you see over the top.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: They're going
to be at the Maps Sandbox
outside after the session,
as will we.
JONAH JONES: And Trulia
have also done a
really good job of this.
This is their house search
that you can see here.
And they've got colors
that are very
harmonious with their brand.
They've also kind of the
de-emphasized the roads and
other information that the
users don't care about.
And they've emphasized the data
that they really want to
present, which is the green
house process you see here.
Now Trulia actually did some
usability studies on their
map, and it turned out that
users really care about the
position of parks in relation
to the houses.
So they made sure that they
were very emphasized.
And you can meet them at the
Maps Sandbox after this
session as well.
And speaking of Trulia, this is
their new commute time map.
This is pretty cool, too.
They've got a black marker in
the middle you can see here.
And then the green places are
places that you can access
quickly from here.
And the orange places
are places that take
a little bit longer.
And this shows the versatility
of this kind of faded base map
that they've got, that they
can overlay information
harmoniously on top.
So to answer, what is the
perfect map for your site,
there are three things
that you're
going to need to consider.
The first is to remove
unnecessary information.
The second is to refine the
data that you have left.
And the third is to test
multiple zooms and regions.
And I'm going to take you
through each of those in turn.
So to remove unnecessary
information, the first thing
you need to consider is,
what is the message
that you want to convey?
And who is the audience
that you want to
convey the message to?
Now once you know the message
and the audience, think about
all the information you need to
convey to them and remove
everything else.
So here's a good example.
This is our New York map that
we have today on Google.
This is pretty general
purpose.
We've got a lot of different
information on here.
We've got road colors
to convey the
different types of road.
We've got some highway
badges you can see
running down the left.
We've got one-way arrows
all over the streets.
We've got points of interest.
You can see little buildings
and stuff.
We've got parks.
We've got transit data.
There's a lot of different
things on here.
But when a user goes to the
Layers menu and turns on the
Transit layer, then we have a
pretty clear signal that the
user cares about
public transit.
So in this case, we can remove
some of the driving
information.
We've taken away the
one-way arrows.
We've taken away the colors
on the streets.
We've taken away the
road badges.
And now when we've added the
public transit lies on there,
you can see that they stand out
a lot more than they would
have done if we'd kept all the
other colors on the map.
Now if we take that to its
logical extreme, we could
actually remove pretty much
all the other information.
So here we've dropped away
a lot of the businesses.
We've taken away the parks.
We've taken away all of
the street labels.
And now the public transit
information really, really
stands out, not because we've
done anything special to the
public transit, but just because
we've removed all the
other unnecessary information.
So it's a very focused
map now.
So we've taken away all the
information we don't want.
What's the next thing to do?
It's to refine the data
we have left.
So to do this, you need to take
into consideration what's
the important data that you want
to convey, and what's the
data that's more kind of
background context
information?
And then choose the colors
and the styles
appropriately to that.
So your primary information,
you want to make sure it
really visually pops.
And then all of the rest of the
information kind of sit
back and don't take too
much attention.
And while we're on the subject
of colors, a good color
scheme, obviously, is something
that you want to
take into consideration, first
to be harmonious with the
general brand of the website
that you're putting it on.
And second of all, color can be
really powerful in creating
an emotional response
with your users.
So if you're going to create a
bright versus a dark map, or a
very colorful or colorless map,
that can really resonate
with your audience in
a different way.
So we'll take you through a
couple of examples again.
Here's a map we quickly
created for
San Francisco parks.
And you can see here that we've
pretty much removed all
the labels except for
the park labels.
So that's removing the
unnecessary information.
And then we've made sure
that the parks are
very prominently colored.
So that's the first thing that
you see, and all the other
information like the roads, and
the background, and the
water and stuff is really the
background information.
And we've picked a really nice
kind of positive, vibrant
color scheme here, so this feels
very natural and good.
And I'll contrast that
with another map.
This is a map all about
San Francisco roads.
Now the information we've
removed this time is
everything except for
the road labels.
And the roads themselves
are dark.
They're very, very prominent.
And in general, we've just
chosen a kind of
heavier color scheme.
So the overall map feels a lot
more serious and more somber.
Going back to Old Maps Online,
you can see when we see the
map now in the context of the
overall site, the whole
experience is very,
very on brand.
Old Maps Online is all about
feeling historical, so they've
got this kind of faded color
scheme, like all the yellows.
And the map really, really
fits in well with that.
And Trulia have the
same story.
Their overall website
[? chrome ?] has got kind of
light greys and light blues,
and that's their general
background color that you
see mirrored on the map.
And then they have this bright
green that they're using as an
emphasis color for the important
information, first
of all, on the website itself,
but also on the map.
And the last thing that you need
to consider is make sure
that the map works in different
zooms and different
regions around the world.
So you can see here that
at far zooms, the main
information we've got are around
countries and country
labels, borders, sometimes you
can see the major highways.
When you move into the
medium zooms, new
information is appearing.
You can then see neighborhoods,
you can see
geographical features like
national parks and things like
that, and the road layout is
actually a very important
thing here.
So you can really see the
difference between the orange
highways and the yellow
arterial roads here.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Arterials
are the roads that
travel through a city.
Generally pretty wide,
may have a median.
JONAH JONES: By the time we
get to the deep zooms, the
things we're really paying
attention to here are the 2D
building footprints, and we've
got some 3D buildings.
You can see some points of
interest around here.
And we've got lots of new
information that appears at
the very deepest zooms.
So it's worth making sure that
you check your map for all of
these different zoom levels.
You can easily imagine that you
could create a map that
looks great in San Francisco
and push that out, and then
you've forgotten to include
something that appears at a
very deep zoom.
So what we would really
recommend is designing your
map for the deep zoom, and then
kind of let it degrade
gracefully as you zoom out,
because we generally tend to
take things away as we zoom out,
rather than add things.
Now speaking of deep zooms,
here's a deep zoom here of
Turkmenistan.
Now this is quite interesting.
You can see that the data
here is super sparse.
So hardly any of the
roads have labels.
We've got a very small
smattering of building
footprints, and of building
information.
We've got one rail line that's
running through that.
Now compare this with the exact
same zoom in Tokyo.
This is crazy busy.
We've got 3D buildings
all over the place.
We've got underground
information, we've got traffic
lights, we've got
business icons.
We've got things all
over the place.
So it's a good idea, again, to
design for this rich data case
and then have it degrade
gracefully.
You don't want to be designing
your local area, which maybe
doesn't have all
the information
that could be elsewhere.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Right, and in
the case of Turkmenistan, we
have Mapmaker in that country
and many other countries of
the world, and so users
can go and add
information at any time.
So you must think about the case
where they have lots and
lots of data.
JONAH JONES: And Japan leads
us to another interesting
issue, which is of local
conventions.
So in many countries around the
world, we use localized
iconography and colors.
So in Japan, for example, you
can see here that they use
green highways.
And this might be quite
different to what you're used
to seeing if you're looking at
a map of Europe or America,
where you see all highways
are orange.
And the UK's another
example of this.
You can see that in the UK,
we've got these blue highways.
So it's worth bearing this
kind of thing in mind.
If you're going to be changing
styles and colors, it might be
affecting local users in a way
that you might not first
anticipate.
So remember, remove the
unnecessary information,
refine the remaining data,
and test it for
multiple zooms and regions.
So I've given you a little hint
of the things you need to
think about to create
your perfect map.
Now I'm going to hand you over
to Scott, who's going to
explain to you how to do it.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT:
Thanks, Jonah.
So Jonah went over the three
principals that can help guide
the design of the map.
I'm going to cover the three
different things to consider
when thinking about how
to implement the
design that you want.
The first thing are stylers.
Stylers are an object or thing
that takes in the existing
style of the map
and mutates it.
It either does that by taking
the input values and tweaking
them, or just overriding them.
Once you can do that, you need
to be able to restrict what
you style on the map.
And there's two ways to
do that restriction.
The first is with feature type,
and the second is with
element type.
Now let's go into those
in more detail.
So stylers, again, they mutate
the existing style of the map.
Many of them are relative, so
we'll go through those first
and then get to the more
powerful ones.
The first relative styler that
we have is the hue styler, and
it takes all the colors of the
map and tints them to one
specific color.
That doesn't mean that it
changes the lightness.
It just means that everything
is tinted towards,
in this case, red.
We also have saturation.
This changes the intensity
of the color for
everything on the map.
Here we're removing the
color altogether
using negative 100%.
You can also increase this.
We also have lightness.
This changes the overall
lightness, again, by
percentage.
And there's two other related
stylers to lightness.
The first is gamma.
Gamma lightens and darkens the
map just like lightness does,
but has a great property of
leaving whites white and
blacks black.
This means that your labels our
labels that typically use
black and white will
be preserved.
They'll still be readable.
And we also have invert
lightness.
This changes the colors from,
say, a light orange to
something that's
a dark orange.
This is great if you have a
dark-themed website, or want
to give a feeling of nighttime
without losing the color
scheme of a typical
Google map.
So those are all relative
stylers.
They've taken in a color, and
they produce another color.
Let's talk a little bit
about more powerful
stylers that we have.
The first is visibility.
Here you can see I've destroyed
the map to some degree.
There is no map anymore.
I've turned everything off.
This is a convoluted example,
but it proves the point.
This is extremely, extremely
powerful, and I can't
reiterate this enough.
In the first step of the design
principles, which is
remove all unnecessary
information,
this is your tool.
Use it, and don't be scared to
use it even more so than you
might have thought.
You can always bring something
back in later stages.
In addition to visibility, we
have a new styler called wait.
This was just added today, we're
really excited about it.
And this changes the thickness
of both the inside of roads
and the outside of roads, and
any other features that are
represented with a line.
So that's available today.
Also available today is color.
Color sets the RGB color of
all the things that you've
selected to that color.
You can see here, again, I've
gone a little bit extreme and
changed the entire map to red.
But it's very, very powerful,
and it's a great tool to get
the map to use the precise
colors that you want for your
brand, or the precise colors
that you want to
complement your data.
If you want to take it back a
step and only use it in a
refined way, here's an example
where I've just changed the
water color to white.
This is a great tool if you want
to move the user's eye
towards the land rather than
the water, because the blue
that we have the water typically
can really draw the
eye away from the land.
So that's a new feature
today, color.
We're really, really, really
excited to see what you come
up with, this new, powerful
styler that we've introduced.
Now let's go into how you can
use these very powerful
stylers in limited ways,
as I've done here.
The first way to do it is by
selecting a feature type.
So features are any place on the
map, and what we've done
is we've categorized them.
Today I'm going to talk about
the top categories in our
hierarchy of features.
Some types have subtypes that
allow you get more granular.
So let's dissect the map of San
Francisco that we've been
using for stylers.
The first feature type we have
is "administrative" features.
These are things such as
cities and provinces.
We have "poi's" This is short
for point of interest.
This includes things such
as parks, coffee shops,
hospitals, and there's also
subtypes to this that will let
you get more granular.
You'll see us use that later.
We also have type "road." This
is all of the roads that cars
can travel on, in addition
to foot paths, which are
typically in things
like parks.
We also have transit.
Transit is all your
mass transit.
You can see here it's rail
lines, and you can see the
BART icons, and also
the ferry lines.
We have feature type
"landscape." This is the
background color.
This is your land color, in
addition to things such as
built up area, if there is
structures in that area or
things like islands.
The last type category we have
is "water." This includes
bays, rivers, lakes, all
that sort of stuff.
So that's feature type.
The other way that we can
break down the map is by
element type.
And I think of elements as the
way we've chosen to represent
a feature on the map.
The first way you can do that
is by selecting all labels.
Here you can see we have both
symbols and icons, in addition
to textual labels that include
the names of the
features on the map.
Today we're announcing that
we're allowing for subtypes of
elements, so sub-element
types.
The first one that we're
introducing today is
"labels.icon." This selects
just the icon so that you
recolor them or turn them
off as you wish.
We're also announcing
"labels.text." This allows you
to do the inverse and just
select the text.
As you can see, it includes the
straight texts that are
for things like parks but also
the curved texts for roads.
Furthermore, we're
sub-categorizing that again
into the "fill," which is the
rendering of the font, and the
name itself, and the stroke.
The stroke is an outline or a
border around that text fill
that is typically used to make
the label more readable by
adding or ensuring contrast
between the
fill and the stroke.
And also, as you can see here,
we have lots of dark orange
and light orange.
And those colors emphasize
which type of roads those
labels are for.
So that's labels.
The other thing that we allow
you to select by element type
is "geometry." This is all the
areas that you see in all the
line features that represent
things such as roads and
rivers, all that
sort of thing.
Today we're also announcing
that we're allowing you to
sub-select geometry in a similar
way to text, where
this is all the fills
of all our geometry.
This is really, really useful
for roads, particularly,
because the inside of the road
is considered the fill, and
the outside of the road is
considered a stroke.
So typically, you'll get strokes
on things like roads,
but you may also get
them around areas
such as land parcels.
So those are all the element
types that you can select.
So we've covered three things.
We've covered all the different
ways you can change
the map with stylers, and then
we've covered the two ways
that you can dissect
the map to reduce
the impact of stylers.
What Jonah and I are going to
do now is we're going to put
both these building blocks I
just covered and the three
design principles into practice
to show you how you
can create the perfect map.
So to start with--
my thumb is weak, apparently.
This is how you show
a Google map.
This is just meant
as an overview.
There were lots of awesome
talks earlier
that covered this.
Things I'd like to point out,
though, is as you can see,
we're loading the Maps
API JavaScript.
We have a dot, dot, dot where
I'm going to add some more
JavaScript later.
And we also have a div
that is where the
map will end up showing.
That's 640x480, and it
has an ID of "map."
So what JavaScript do we use?
What we do is we add an init
function that gets called once
the window is loaded.
And then within that function,
we set the map options, which
set things like the default
zoom, the center that we want,
and the base or the
map type that we
want to show by default.
In this case, it's just the
standard Google roadmap.
And we do that, we take those
options and we pass that into
our construction of the map
object that also takes the
development that we want
the map to show up in.
So now that we've got a standard
Google map, how do we
make it our styled map?
Here's the changes that
you need to make.
We need to create a styled map
type that we can use just like
any other map type.
To create a styled map
type, we provide
two different things.
We provide all the styles
that we want to apply to
the Google base map.
This is a list of different
styles, and we'll show you
examples of what a style
is a little bit later.
And then we also provide it
with map options, which
include things such as the
name of the map type that
you're creating.
Here you can see I've also--
sorry.
Now that we have that object, we
want to set our ID to that
map type object so we can
switch between all the
different types of maps,
and that's what
I've done at the end.
I've also created this ID as a
constant so that we can have
the map default to it also.
So that's how you use
a styled map.
Here's Jonah to walk through
how you create the
design for your map.
JONAH JONES: OK.
So we're going to create a map
of people who like dogs versus
people who like cats
in San Francisco.
So we'll say that the dog lovers
are going to be the red
dots here, and the cat
lovers are going to
be the green dots.
And we've got quite a lot
of information going
on on the map here.
We've probably got too
many colors, I think.
We've got all the yellows of
the roads and the greens of
the parks, and that's
interfering a little bit with
the information we're
trying to overlay.
And also, there's too many
labels on there, like I think
we're trying to read the labels
a little bit much.
And also, the labels look
awkward with the
overlaid data on top.
So I think what we want
is something a
bit more like this.
Now here, you can see that the
information is really standing
out very prominently, and then
the background information of
the map is really sinking back
for context, and it's not
grabbing your attention.
So how can we create something
like this?
We'll start back with
the base map.
Now I suppose the obvious thing
to do is probably just
to desaturate this map
completely and
get rid of the labels.
So let's give that a try.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: So here you can
see an example of how to
use a sequence of styles to
create the map that you want.
We have two styles here.
First, we have one that
has no element type
and no feature type.
This means that it applies to
everything on the map, and so
we're desaturating
that by 100%.
We have a second style that is
restricted to only labels.
And for that, we turn them
all off using visibility.
JONAH JONES: OK, so this looks
all right, but it's kind of
looking a bit crude.
Like something that's really
bugging me here is the water
is very, very similar color
to the parks now.
So they're kind of blending
into each other.
The roads are quite visually
noisy, like they're
distracting me a little bit.
Like especially, you can
see the highways,
they're very dark.
And it's just in general,
like there's a lot
of patches and lines.
I think we can do a lot
better than this.
So let's start again.
And we'll go back to the
first principle.
And first of all, we'll remove
some of the unnecessary
information.
So the most obvious candidate
here is the labels.
They're pretty much just there
distracting you, causing you
to read them.
And we can assume for the
purposes of this example that
the users are familiar
with San Francisco.
So we'll go ahead and get
rid of the labels.
And that is immediately
looking a ton better.
But now I'm starting to notice
a few more things, like you
can see kind of in the middle
of the map there, we've got
some brown and pink patches.
These are actually the
universities and the
hospitals, and they're actually
part of the points of
interest, the POIs.
So we don't need these for the
purposes of this demo, so
we'll get rid of those
ones as well.
And now I've just made a
mistake, because we've just
gotten rid of the parks, too.
So we'll have to bring
those back.
But for the meantime, we'll have
a little look at the rest
of what's going on.
The next most obvious thing is
these kind of dark-colored
transit lines that you see
running horizontally and
vertically.
And also, you can see the little
dotted ferry lines in
the top-right corner here.
So again, we don't really
need this information.
We'll get rid of that, too.
And now we've got a fairly
minimal map.
I think right now, we're
probably done with removing
the information.
So now it's time to refine
the information
that we've got left.
Now the water is looking pretty
heavy at the moment.
I think that's probably
the main colored
element on the screen.
This is drawing our attention.
So we don't really want that.
I quite liked what Scott did
earlier, which was to remove
the water and change
it to white.
So I think let's do that, and
that will give us a nice,
clean background canvas
to work from.
And so this is immediately
looking a lot better.
And this introduces the new
feature that we've got today
to recolor things directly.
So now this park thing's
bugging me.
So let's bring the
parks back again.
I don't think we'd want them to
be a fully prominent green.
So we'll just use a quiet,
subtle gray, because we want
them there for context and
orientation of the map, but
not to be something that
you really notice.
So here's the parks added
back in again.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: As you can see,
we just have individual
styles on the left
side, typically.
The expectation is that we're
adding those to the
list that we have.
And so to turn on parks, we
don't need to go back and
change the POI visibility off.
We can simply add another
style that selects our
poi.park, which is just our
parts and just their geometry,
and then turn them on in
addition to coloring them.
JONAH JONES: And again, it's
important to note, as Scott
said, we are bringing just the
geometry back in here.
If we'd forgotten to include
that, then we'd have brought
the labels back in, which
isn't what we wanted.
So this is now looking
fairly good.
The obvious last thing to
remove now is the roads.
Now we want to keep the roads
on the map because they're
good for, again, orientation,
but we don't
really need the colors.
And I don't think we need a
distinction between the stroke
and the fill here.
It's just adding visual noise.
So let's simplify these.
And we've just given them a
kind of grey fill here.
So this is now nearly done.
I think probably the last thing
we should do here is the
roads are still looking just
that tiny little bit too
heavy, still a little bit fat.
So we can refine these a little
bit further with the
new width control that we've
announced today and make them
a bit thinner.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Yeah, so as
you can see here, we're
setting the weight of the three
different types of roads.
What's interesting is that we're
setting the arterials
and the locals to
the same weight.
The reason this doesn't screw up
our hierarchy where we want
the highways to be fatter than
the arterials, and the
arterials to be fatter than the
local roads is because in
San Francisco, arterials are
typically separated by a
median, which means we actually
draw two lines next
to each other and causes them
to look fat, even though the
weights are identical to the
weight of the local road.
JONAH JONES: And this may not
be the case everywhere.
In different parts of the world,
it could be that the
arterials are done as one road
instead of two, in which case
the arterial road thing we've
got here would probably need
to be 1 or 0.75, or something
like that to maintain that
sense of hierarchy.
But for San Francisco
here, this is
looking great, actually.
So I think we can add our dogs
and cats data back again.
And this is looking
pretty good.
There's one problem here, which
is that this is probably
fine to most of you, but maybe
a couple of you in the
audience are seeing something
a bit more like this.
This is what you'll see if
you're colorblind, where reds
and greens, distinguishing
between them can
be a bit of a problem.
So there's a few different
approaches you could use to
combat this.
One good one is to just change
the brightness of
the red and the green.
We actually do this on
our traffic layer.
Another one would be to change
the shapes, so maybe the red
things would be triangles
and the green
things would be circles.
We actually considered using
cute little cats and dogs on
the map, but we thought
that was a bit cheesy.
So for now we'll just give
it a nice Google I/O
themed set of colors.
And there we have it.
We've got nice map
of San Francisco.
We can clearly visualize
the data on top.
It's taken us about
10 minutes.
That's not bad.
So the next stage would
be to check the
different zooms and regions.
But something I didn't mention
before is there's actually a
clever little trick here
than we can do.
So I'll give you Scott back
to introduce you that.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Thank you.
So Jonah and I work
on Google Maps.
And because we work on Google
Maps, we have to think about
everyone in the entire world.
That's a good thing.
We like that.
But it makes it really hard
to get a design that works
everywhere.
In addition to that, we have
to check every zoom level.
We have 20 different zoom levels
that we have a map on,
and a design that works
for zoom 4 may not
work for zoom 17.
However, you guys have a better
idea of what your users
want from your map, so you can
restrict both the zooms that
the user looks at, and the
places in the world that they
can see on your map.
So how do you do that?
To restrict the zoom, you simply
set the min zoom and
the max zoom on the
map options before
you create your map.
Here you can see I've used a
variable for my default zoom
so that if I want to change
my default, it's easy.
That's what the zoom option on
the object is, is also the
default zoom.
And then I'm just allowing
two more zoom levels
in addition to that.
So that's restricting zoom.
Restricting the center is
a little bit trickier.
What I have here is a
LatLngBounds at the top that
the center of the view port
will be restricted to.
In our example, this is a rough
bounding box for the
data that we're showing.
And then on every center changed
event callback, we
take the center of the map, we
see if it's in those bounds,
and if it is in those
bounds, we're done.
Otherwise we need to move
it back into the bounds.
And we do that by capping the
latitude and the longitude and
then resetting the center
of our map.
So now that we've restricted
the zoom in the center, we
know where people are
going to look at.
Jonah's design was only done
for zoom 13, so let's check
the other two zooms that we're
going to allow them to see.
So this is zoom 14.
It looks good.
There's nothing that
we didn't expect.
You can see the nice Golden Gate
Park there running across
the screen, along with the
Presidio above it.
I think it looks good.
So zoom 14 looks fine.
However, zoom 15 doesn't
look fine.
On Google Maps at zoom 15, we
introduce land parcels.
And in this case, the land
parcels are really distracting
because they're adding a lot
of visual noise to the map,
which is exactly what we
tried to avoid in the
design that we did.
So using the styling API, we
can simply take them off.
Here you can see I've added
a style that says for
administrative features, which
land parcels are a part of,
turn them off.
We don't need it.
One way we could do that is by
appending it to all the styles
that I showed you earlier.
Another cleverer way is to
do it only for zoom 15.
So how do you change the style
of the map for a given zoom?
Here's a code snippet
that I've done.
You can see what I'm doing is
I'm listening for the zoom
changed event, and whenever I
get that, I'm changing the
styled map type that's
associated with
our map type ID.
I'm doing that using
an object.
So I just give it the zoom to
the object, the styles per
zoom object.
I give it the zoom, and then
I'll get back the particular
styled map type that I want.
As I explained it, the adminOff
was just an addition
to our previous style.
So I've used a rate
concatenation in JavaScript to
just add it to the one
zoom that we need it.
So our one live demo.
Here we have it all working.
Or no.
What did I click?
If you wanted to see it all
again, here you go.
All right.
Don't click anything.
So as you can see, this is a
live version of the demo that
we just walked through.
And as I pull up, I
get constrained.
I can't move any further.
That's great because we then
don't need to worry about what
this looks like in some
place such as Seattle.
And we can zoom in.
Our circles stay the same.
The circles are being done with
the new symbols API we
launched yesterday.
And we can zoom in to zoom 15
again, and now we can't zoom
in anymore.
So that's our live demo.
Let's wrap up.
JONAH JONES: All right.
So we've given you three
principles for the design that
you should remember.
The first is to remove the
unnecessary information.
The second is to refine the data
that you have left, and
the third is to test it at
multiples zooms and regions
that we've just seen here.
And we've also announced some
new features, which is
changing the weight of roads and
strokes, being able to set
the color directly, which is
awesome and very powerful, and
also being able to select
the fill and the stroke
individually.
And we hope that if you use all
of these new things we've
announced today, then you'll be
able to create the perfect
map for your site.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: We can't
wait to see what you
guys come up with.
Thank you for coming.
We're excited for all
these new features.
If you have questions
we'll take them now.
Please use the mics because
this is being recorded.
If you'd like to talk to us
personally, we're planning on
heading over to the Sandbox
right after the session.
In addition to us being at the
Sandbox, representatives from
Trulia, Old Maps Online,
and UbiLabs--
another awesome user of
custom map styling--
will be there.
If you liked the session, also
please drop a +1 in the box.
Any questions?
JONAH JONES: We have one.
AUDIENCE: Can static
maps be styled?
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Yes.
I got a thumbs up.
AUDIENCE: OK, because I had an
idea where as soon as my page
loads, I show a static map.
And then after half a second,
when the full JavaScript map
loads, I'd replace it,
and hopefully the
user wouldn't notice.
I don't know if that
would work.
AUDIENCE: So we actually
do that for you.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: So for those
of you watching at home, the
JavaScript API does
this trick.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Well, thanks.
AUDIENCE: But not if you're
using a styled map.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: But not if
you're using a static map.
AUDIENCE: Styled map.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Styled map.
AUDIENCE: Not the styles.
OK.
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: I work on the
rendering part of it, not the
JavaScript side.
AUDIENCE: So the second question
is I still want my
users to be able to switch
to satellite view.
Can they do a hybrid with our
styled roads on top of
satellite imagery?
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Yes, you
can style hybrid also.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Do you have support
for transparent maps, so I
could, like, have labels on top
of something else I draw?
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: Not at the
moment, but it's something
we've heard from other people.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
it's important to keep certain
elements on the map for context
and orientation.
And I think it would be
important at least have the
label California, and San
Francisco, but hide all the
other road names.
Is that possible?
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: It's possible
to only show administrative
labels, such as cities.
So localities are what we
typically call cities, and you
can leave those explicitly.
There's no way to ensure
currently that a label such as
San Francisco alone
will show up.
AUDIENCE: So would the names of
parks still show up, then,
in that case?
JONAH JONES: The
parks will go.
You'll hold on to city names
and the neighborhood names.
But you can get rid
of all the parks.
You can get rid of the road
labels, all of those things.
So depending on which bucket
that it fits into, you can
turn on the big ones.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
That should be it for me.
AUDIENCE: Can I style points
and polygons that I've
uploaded with the Google
Apps Engine?
SCOTT SHAWCROFT: There is
a separate API for that.
JONAH JONES: All right.
Well, we'll be around in the
Sandbox, so if there's any
questions you want to give to us
in person instead of on the
mic, we'll be very happy
to hear them.
But other than that, yeah,
thanks for coming.
And we're excited to see
what you come up with.